we're going to begin in Sudan where
sporadic gunfire is being heard across
the capital Khartoum
as despite an extension of a faltering
ceasefire for another 72 hours in
humanitarian grounds both sides have
repeatedly accused each other of
breaking the truce Morgan's life for us
in cartoon do people there think this
ceasefire is actually going to be any
different to the last one
well people aren't paying attention or
they're not really optimistic about the
fact that there is yet another ceasefire
they've seen how the previous ceasefires
played out with fighting in many parts
of the capital Khartoum like the
northern part of the capital Bahari as
well as the city of Honduran up until
yesterday so people aren't observing the
ceasefire to see how it's going to play
out and instead what they're doing is
they're focusing to see when their brief
loads of fighting for them to either be
able to make it out of the capital or to
try to get their basic Commodities if
the markets and shops are open hospitals
are still out of service in many parts
of the capital so those who are in need
are trying to get assistance medical
assistance based on community uh
Community contributions and Community
coordination because many many hospitals
and many doctors have have been unable
to work since the fighting started but
but the banks are still closed many
institutions in the country has been
closed it was supposed to be the start
of of the working week yesterday but
because of the ongoing fighting there
has been indefinite holiday here in the
capital Khartoum while other states
resume people say that that's making
their lives harder because they can't
access money they can't access financial
institutions and in many places they
can't access hospitals or markets to get
their basic needs
Heather thank you very much indeed him
and Morgan talking to us from Khartoum
well I continued fighting is making it
difficult for thousands of people trying
to leave Sudan many are making a
treacherous journey to Port Sudan in the
northeastern Coast to board evacuation
ships thousands are packed into the area
some have waited for days for a chance
to leave many of them are syrians who
fled a Civil War in their own country
and have now been uprooted again
Sudan's living through a moment of real
terror real terror I'm talking about
dead bodies in the streets we smell the
dead bodies as we were coming from
Khartoum the firing the shelling Sudan
is seriously in a state of real war
we are around three to five thousand the
number is large inside the port and also
along the Corniche people are sleeping
on the ground widows children elderly
the ill everyone
you know the violence in Sudan's
interrupting the supply of goods to
Eastern Chad and that means prices have
gone up and many people can't afford
basic items now we're going to speak to
Ahmad Idris shortly he's going to be
live from Audrey near Chad's border with
Sudan first he describes how people are
having to adapt to Rising costs
Adam Ibrahim dahab has come to our Dream
Market to buy groceries
only to discover he can't afford many of
them
now he says his family must adjust
previously we could afford three to four
meals a day not anymore eating twice a
day these days is difficult because food
has become so expensive
the village of address is an important
trading point but the fighting across
the border in Sudan has changed
everything for many people here
while there has been a steady stream of
refugees at this Crossing Point into
Eastern chart the flow of goods have
been severely disrupted fighting has
almost cut off this side of landlocked
child from sudanesports that Supply many
of the Imports it needs
Refugee and Trader who brought his stock
with him he explains why things can only
get worse in the coming weeks
the prices have gone up because
airstrikes hit our main Goods Depot in
Khartoum the road is closed so
transporting any Goods is very difficult
anyone with stock will now try to sell
at a higher price
back at Audrey Market vendors struggled
to find buyers for items that only a few
can afford
business is slow but we're grateful
local authorities say prices especially
food items have risen by up to 70 in a
matter of weeks
and that the government is looking for
Solutions planning to subsidize some
Goods
it's an additional burden on a country
where millions of people are already
struggling to put food on the table
Ahmad Idris Al Jazeera address
who's that now the refugee camp in adre
in Chad so that was the impact that the
the refugees and the situation in Sudan
is having on people in chat itself what
kind of conditions are people facing
when they arrive at the camp
women
well basically uh by the way this is the
address Market but at the camp we
visited our people are in Desperate
conditions uh more than two weeks after
this flow of refugees started coming
into Eastern China there is no single
tent for anybody on all the camps we've
visited so far people are just living
out there in the open the lucky ones are
taking shelter under the trees the
United Nations organizations and other
donor agencies are on the ground but
then when you talk to refugees who cross
over they tell you that they are hungry
they lack water they lack shelter and
they like food and the amount of food
given to them is not enough to last them
a week that's the story they're giving
us
I mean thank you very much indeed as
Ahmed you're just talking to us from our
Dream Market in Chad we're going to get
a situation an idea of the situation
enabling South Sudan now which we're
going to bring in our correspondent
harobatasa who's joining us from Juba
um how do I I'm just describing the
situation uh in Chad very very difficult
not only for refugees but for the people
that are there who are having to deal
with Rising costs what kind of situation
are they facing Where You Are
thank you
well the influx of people coming into
South Sudan is putting a lot of pressure
on scarce resources here South Sudan had
his own crisis they saw violence in some
parts of the country and eight agencies
say there's not enough money to help
everybody so what local businesses are
doing at least here in Juba they are
pulling their resources together so
you've seen the shops they are
collecting food and medicines and they
this these supplies have been taken to
the local airport they put on Chicago
planes and taken to the border with
Sudan to help people who are still stuck
there South Sudan has a very close
relationship with Sudan this used to be
one country until South Sudan broke away
from Sudan in 2011 and gained
independence but the two companies don't
work together president salvakia South
Sudan's leader says that he has closed
ties with all the military factions in
Sudan he says he's talking to all the
players every day on the telephone he's
trying to get them to come here to Judah
to have face-to-face talks trying to end
the conflict in Sudan but right now of
course the concern is the people trying
to come in into the country most of them
are from South Sudan so when they get
here they say with family and friends
those who have nowhere else to go will
probably end up at the many cabins for
this place people scattered across the
country it is a huge crisis for this
country with limited resources as more
and more people keep flooding in
Otto thank you very much indeed that's
haramutasa bringing us up to date from
Juba
well back in Sudan the international
Committee of the Red Cross has delivered
its first shipment of humanitarian Aid
it includes about eight tons of medical
supplies to help Physicians treat
wounded civilians the aid agency says
it's going to need guarantees that it
can safely transport supplies in hostile
areas including the capital Khartoum
Ariana signenko is a spokeswoman for the
international Committee of the Red Cross
and she says the fighting is posing
serious challenges
it was incredibly difficult from the
logistical and security perspective
perspects because the civilian flights
are canceled and the air space over
Sudan has been closed so it was
incredibly difficult to find the way to
bring the supplies into the country and
Port Sudan was the most uh
appropriate place where we were able to
bring this first shipment but now even
bigger challenged is lying ahead of us
because now we also need to ensure that
these supplies can reach hospitals that
are treating the wounded people on the
front lines and this is going to part we
are talking about surgical supplies
there's surgical materials for Anastasia
the surgical material that should enable
us to stabilize some 1500 wounded people
so these These are the first uh the
material of like of the first necessity
for the surgeons to be able to treat the
wounded people quickly